-JoJo, you're a great dancer,
so I wanted to challenge
you to a dance-off.
-Okay, fair enough.
-But I don't want to know
who can dance the best.
I want to know
who can dance the hardest.
-Okay, I like it.
-It's time for a "Tonight Show"
Aggressive Dance-off!
Here we go.
-Let's do it!
-Okay.
-♪ Aggressive ♪
-♪ Aggressive! ♪
-♪ Da-ance-off ♪
-♪ Da-ance! Yeah! ♪
-Now, here's how
it's going to work.
We'll be given a series of dance
moves,
then we'll have to do
each of them
as aggressively as possible.
When you hear a ding, you have
to move on to the next dance.
-Okay.
-I will go first.
JoJo, you better stand
over there
because things
are about to get intense.
-All right, good luck,
good luck!
-Thank you.
Yeah, I don't even need it.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wow. Okay.
-I'm getting into character now.
-Okay, sounds good.
-Roots, can I get a beat?
♪♪
[ Ding! ]
-Let's see it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right!
[ Ding! ]
Oh, whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
That's it! Go! Go!
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! Ding! Ding! Ding! ]
-What's up?
-Good job. Good job.
That was good.
-Thanks.
-That was good.
-Whew!
-Feeling good? Can you breathe?
-Grandpa needs a nap.
-Can I get an oxygen tank
on set?!
-All right, JoJo, you're up.
-Okay.
-[ Sighs ] Roots, give her
a beat when you're ready.
♪♪
-Oh, yeah. All right!
[ cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-That was good actually.
-What do I have to do?
Oh, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's aggressive! Oh!
That's aggressive!
[ Ding! ]
-Ohh! Let's go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Ding! Ding! Ding! Ding! ]
-Oh, my God. [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not bad.
-Wow!
-Not too shabby.
-Thank you.
-You can dance.
-This time, I can.
-Oh, gosh.
That was pretty good,
but there's only one way to find
out who is the most aggressive
dancer by going head to head.
For the final round, we'll be
dancing at the same time.
-Okay.
Should we take a breather?
-I definitely need one,
but it's okay.
You ready for this?
-Let's do it!
-Let's do it. Roots?
♪♪
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Doing good.
[ Ding! ]
-Jimmy!
-Sorry. Sorry.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How was that?
[ Ding! Ding! Ding! Ding! ]
-We have a winner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's JoJo Siwa, everybody,
the champ!